el gobierno ecuatoriano dispuestos toda
la protección necesaria para la fiscal
general del estado Diana Salazar Es que
la titular de la fiscalía general del
estado ha recibido denuncias de muertes
a través de medios digitales un video
que circula en las redes sociales en el
que un grupo armado le indica tener
todas sus ubicaciones que tome las
decisiones adecuadas y advierten de
atentar contra su vida el presidente de
la república Guillermo lasso anunció que
no permitirá que grupos armados atenten
contra la seguridad de autoridades del
Estado la fiscalía general del estado
también emitió un comunicado donde
rechaza las intimidaciones por hacer su
trabajo de investigación y se asigna la
Policía Nacional para protegerla además
hizo un llamado a la comunidad
internacional a mantenerse vigilantes de
lo que ya calificado como intento por
tomarse la institución por la fuerza
Diana Salazar también enfrenta
investigaciones en su contra que
aseguran que la titular de la fiscalía
habría supuestamente plagiado su tesis
de grado afirmaciones que ella ha negado
en todo momento de comprobarse el
supuesto plagio de su tesis
esto podría significar la destitución de
su cargo la titular de la fiscalía
declaró recientemente que se trata de
interesados que intentan tomar el
control de la institución por la fuerza
y señaló directamente a expresidente y a
un ex vicepresidente de la República
como supuestos involucrados